THERE HE'S QUITE A STORY FILLING
IN
KIVIRANTA AND ALEXANDER RADULOV
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE ST. LOUIS
BLUES ON THEIR FIRHIS WILL
TAKE NEARLY AS LONG.
WUNGS AGAIN THE BLUES ABLE TO
CHANGE ATTACK. ABLE TO TEST
LINDGREN ON NET ALL THAT OFTEN.
ONLY POWER PLAY OF THE AWAY, PAE
IN, CHALLENGED
HEISKANEN.
HIGH FOR SUTER.
NOW DID THE R THIRD
BEST GOALS IN AGAINST.ERE AGAINS
BY TARASENKO, BREAKING  IN.
HEISKANE
KLINGBERG.
ON THE ATTACK.
SHOULDERED OFF BYNOTHER SHOT.
DAMIANI, THE FLY BY. SCORED,
DAMIANI WITH THE CHANCE AND
V W
THE BLUE LINE.
IT WAS THE INTERCHANGE WITH ROB
ANOTHER OUT.
AT HIS OWN BLUE LINE.
BUYS TIME ONN
DON'T BURP THE P
THIS ONE TO ST. LOUIS, BORTUZZO.
SUNDQVIST. PUMP IT BACK TO THE
LINE AND WITH THE BODIES
STARS HAVE TO PUNCH OUT.
RYAN O'REILLY
>>> PROTECTION PLAYS, PLURAL,
>> Daryl: THAT'S A STRONG PLAY
BY
BIG GUY.
HAKANPAA
IT'S A 2-1 ST. LOUIS
>> Daryl: YEAH, CHEEKY THERE.
GOOD PASS.
O'REILLY.
BACK TO THE NEAR SIDE.
CONTINUED TO DRIBBLE THROUGH AND
JUST AS OETTINGER REACHED OUT S
KILLS BY DALLAS.
STREAK BEGAN AGAINST THE BLU
THEY'VE GOT THE MULTI-GOAL LEADN
THE STARS FROM RIGHT